que el presidente Díaz canela apostó por
un gobierno de continuismo pero la
difícil coyuntura económica cubana le
permitirá a este país cinco años más de
continuismo o es el momento de hacer
reformas necesarias
Santiago Buenas noches
el presidente Díaz canela efectivamente
fue reelecto el día de hoy con
cuatrocientos cincuenta y nueve de esos
462 votos posibles en una elección donde
difícilmente los diputados pueden tomar
una decisión diferente el partido
comunista garantiza que antes de tomar
estas decisiones efectivamente se
garantice la continuidad de la decisión
que se haya tomado previamente Y esa
decisión mantenía la continuidad no
solamente de Díaz canel sino también de
Salvador Valdés y también del resto de
de la plana mayor de el estado cubano
Manuel marrero fue elegido también por
Miguel Díaz canel y Esteban lazo al
frente de la asamblea nacional del poder
popular situación económica no solamente
ha sido compleja estos años sino que
promete mantener este esta complejidad
pero hay que notar que sobre todo se ha
hecho por decisiones de el mismo Miguel
Díaz canel en el año 2021 a del año 2021
se tomó la decisión de lo que se conoció
como la tarea de ordenamiento formulada
precisamente por el ministro de economía
Gil y con la batuta de Miguel Díaz canel
y lo contrario de lo que se esperaba
terminó generando resultados aún más
negativos señor Ángel muy puntual por
favor también vimos Durante este primer
periodo del presidente Díaz canel
históricas manifestaciones ciudadanas y
un aumento también del Éxodo de cubanos
tal y como lo veíamos en los años 90
durante el periodo especial este
malestar ciudadano continúa Cómo puede
afrontar esto el presidente cubano
es una situación aún más crítica
solamente
a la frontera de Estados Unidos llegaron
240 mil cubanos en el último año fiscal
2021-2022 esto deja ver que es una
crisis sin precedentes incluso superior
a la crisis de la década de los noventas
durante el período especial no se ha
reducido de manera significativa pese a
las mismas medidas migratorias que ha
tomado el gobierno de Estados Unidos y
los acercamientos para tomar nuevas
decisiones en esta materia la situación
al interior de Cuba sigue siendo crítica
en materia de hambre en materia de
combustibles en materia de empleo y
trabajo en términos generales y sobre
todo en materia de abastecimiento como
lo decía anteriormente las medidas del
gobierno han ido en contra vía
precisamente de solventar esto para la
sociedad civil de a pie una de las
medidas fue precisamente la
incorporación de tiendas en moneda
libremente convertible en Divisas
mientras que los cubanos siguen ganando
en pesos cubanos una inflación
desbordada desabastecimiento en moneda
en en tiendas en moneda nacional una
libreta que ya no alcanza dejan al
pueblo cubano en en ascuas y en